your oscar-winning host for the 74th
annual Academy Awards knew Whoopi
Goldberg
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening darlings I am the original
sexy beast
welcome to the 74th annual Academy
Awards what a night
movie stars Oscar winners great big
party my god is this licensed wedding
I'm just cracking you up on it
go ahead Julia laugh out loud child but
can you believe this year can you
believe this campaign so much mud has
been thrown this year all the nominees
look black I tell you this negative
campaigning has got to stop I got an
email today that said Frodo Baggins was
an anti-semite
tonight marks the debut of Oscars new
house the Kodak beautiful is that
actually the Academy wanted to stay at
the old place
but the network thought they should go
with a younger theater
y'all better cut me some slack we're
gonna be together a while you know I say
that but Oscar is after all 74 years old
he's almost enough to get almost old
enough to get flowers for a mother Anna
Nicole Smith
[Applause]
I'm sorry you having dinner with her you
know Oscar is the only 74 year old man
in Hollywood who doesn't need viagra to
last three hours now you know this has
been a hell of a year I mean America's
suffered through a great national
tragedy but we have recovered Mariah
Carey has already made another movie
naturally some things have changed
security here tonight is tighter than
some of the faces
and you know before I got on the trapeze
I asked them if they had taken safety
precautions
they said yes Billy Crystal oh look this
Smith family was seated together will
Jada and Maggie Smith
oK we've got many many great movies to
celebrate tonight Ali Gosford Park iris
a movie that even ignore Bergman found
depressing
but I just want to tell you once again I
want to prepare you this show is going
to be long but not as long as it took to
explain Mulholland Drive
and this year we decided to be like the
Winter Olympics and give both statues to
everyone